Killer Robots Alien Invaders and David
Bowie yes the 1970s had it all keep
watching for the best sci-fi movies of
this weird and wonderful decade today
Westworld is better known as an
acclaimed HBO series but the show was
actually spawned from a once forgotten
1973 film that mixed gunslinging action
with sci-fi Brilliance written by
Jurassic Park author Michael Crichton
Westworld was his directorial debut and
just his second original screenplay
Westworld is a futuristic Adventure
starring Yul Brenner in a deliberate
homage to his role in The Magnificent
Seven Ten Years into the future the
delos Corporation has created a series
of theme parks for the wealthy One Park
aptly known as Westworld is an
extravagant Recreation of the Wild West
adult guests can indulge in any desire
they wish but when a series of cascading
program errors and system malfunctions
spread throughout the parks westworld's
Androids develop minds of their own I'm
shot what
I'm shot
one of several films to warn of the
coming dangers of artificial
intelligence and robot technology
Westworld was praised by variety for its
chilling topicality and suburbly
intelligent serial comic story values
it was followed by a lesser sequel
future world and a single season TV
spin-off Beyond Westworld not every
great 70s science fiction film was a
blockbuster released in 1970 Colossus
the forbin project is an underrated
classic that crosses genres being equal
parts frightening science fiction
Parable and riveting political thriller
based on a novel by Dennis baltham Jones
the movie warns of the dangers of
artificial intelligence in a grim near
future on the brink of War Dr Charles
forbin has designed a highly intelligent
supercomputer called Colossus which is
intended to control the nuclear arsenal
of the United States and its allies soon
however forbin realizes that the Soviet
Union has their own device and he and
his colleagues watch helplessly as the
two AI systems begin to work together a
gripping science fiction Thriller
Colossus the forbin project dispenses
with action and adventure instead opting
for a slow deliberately paced narrative
set mostly in boardrooms and control
rooms what the movie lacks in action
however it more than makes up for in
suspense in the late 1960s an aspiring
young director named George Lucas
crafted a 15-minute science fiction
short about a totalitarian state that
Demands a total lack of emotion from its
citizens it was titled electronic
Labyrinth
thx-1138 4eb the movie became the basis
for one of the first projects
distributed by Warner Brothers under the
American zoetrope Banner a production
house started by Francis Ford Coppola to
nurture creative young talent and
independent filmmaking the full-length
feature
thx-1138 was Lucas's feature film debut
thx1138 is set in an underground World
devoid of Love passion hate or anger as
Free Will and thought are squashed by
the state when one man and one woman
stopped taking the medication that
suppresses feelings however they are
confronted by the true horror of their
world and fall in love in the process
they experience emotions for the first
time and immediately become fugitives
from the law a glimpse into a harrowing
future
thx-1138 gained more attention after the
release of Lucas's Star Wars and has
since become a revered classic for its
exploration of the nature of free will
you do
for a living I mean oh just visiting
many cult classics can stake a claim
among the best sci-fi films of the 1970s
but none are quite as unusual and
offbeat as the man who fell to Earth
most notable perhaps for its lead
performance by David Bowie the film was
barely given a theatrical release
reportedly because Paramount Executives
were so perplexed by it over the years
however the man who fell to Earth has
garnered a passionate fan following not
just for Bowie's charming and affecting
performance but also its Eerie tone and
compelling story Bowie stars as an alien
who hails from a world on which an
environmental crisis has left the planet
dry and Barren coming to Earth seeking
water he takes on a human identity and
sets himself up as the CEO of a major
technology firm in order to save his
Homeworld soon though he becomes a
wealthy Tycoon and slowly Falls prey to
Earth's many Temptations including the
love of a beautiful woman today the man
who fell to Earth is considered a bona
fide sci-fi Gem and its influence lives
on in a surprising limited series remake
that was launched in 2022
it's hard to remake a classic movie and
do it justice but the 1978 Invasion of
the Body Snatchers did just that and
then some retelling the same story as
the 1956 film of the same name sometimes
cited as one of the best remakes ever
the film brought the story of a Sinister
Alien Invasion into the 1970s mixing it
with the tone of the decade's best
political Thrillers and loading it with
relevant social commentary in this
frightening reboot of the original movie
we meet San francisco-based scientific
researcher Elizabeth Driscoll who is
Disturbed when her boyfriend begins
acting strangely it soon becomes clear
that a strange Alien Force is creating
duplicates of human beings forcing
Driscoll and her allies to flee from a
city of doppelgangers a stunning
suspense-filled Alien Invasion story
with few equals Invasion of the Body
Snatchers also happens to boast one of
the bleakest endings in sci-fi movie
history the sub-genre of
post-apocalyptic sci-fi gained steam in
the 1970s and it arguably reached its
Zenith with the ultra low budget
Australian film Mad Max George Miller's
ability to carefully craft a high
quality futuristic action movie on a
shoestring budget shook the filmmaking
world with a cottage industry of
wannabes springing up in its wake
in Mad Max most of society has all but
Fallen apart due to global oil shortages
as survivors try to eke out a meager
living local Warlords and gangs of
Ruthless bikers attempt to take
advantage of the chaos but one of the
last remnants of organized law
enforcement a cop named Max rocketansky
is out to stop them still one of the
best movies of a genre Mad Max was a
sensation in its native Australia thanks
to its gear grinding action and
over-the-top violence
it found just as much success Stateside
turning Mel Gibson into a star and
kick-starting George Miller's
directorial career eventually followed
by a pair of sequels Mad Max was later
rebooted in 2015 with Mad Max Fury Road
a critically acclaimed Blockbuster that
reignited the franchise for the 21st
century
oh what a day
The Man Behind Some of the best movies
of all time Stanley Kubrick also
directed one of the greatest dystopian
sci-fi Classics A Clockwork Orange based
on the celebrated 1962 novel by Anthony
Burgess the movie stars Malcolm McDowell
and a broad ensemble cast of
lesser-known actors in a story about a
dismal future that mixes unsettling
surrealism with sharp social commentary
a film that often borders on the
avant-garde A Clockwork Orange revolves
around Alex delarge in eccentric Street
Punk who leads in Ultra violent gang of
thugs as they steal assault and murder
innocent people eventually Alex is
apprehended by the authorities who force
him to undergo a brutal form of
brainwashing a film that cinematically
breathtaking and disturbing in equal
measure A Clockwork Orange is today
considered to be one of the truly iconic
films of the 1970s young director Steven
Spielberg had done plenty of work for
television in the early 1970s and his
transition to feature films yielded
results almost immediately in his second
film Jaws he produced one of the biggest
hits of the decade in popularized the
term Blockbuster to follow it up he
turned up Science Fiction with a
poignant story that mixed family drama
and an outer space mystery the 1977
classic Close Encounters of the Third
Kind while Star Wars blue audiences away
with its fast-moving in-space Opera
action Spielberg went a different route
opting for an emotional drama told
through a story of alien visitation here
Family Man Roy Neri is contacted by an
extraterrestrial intelligence and
becomes a conduit for communication when
they arrive on Earth niri's personal
Journey sits at the heart of the film as
he struggles to understand what is
happening while his family life
deteriorates around him a visually
captivating experience that fuses
mystery Terror wonder and awe Close
Encounters of the Third Kind was
nominated for nine Academy Awards
including best director for Spielberg
while it may not have been the biggest
sci-fi film at the box office in 1977 it
was probably the most moving based on a
novel by polish author stanislaw lamb
The Landmark film Solaris might be
Russia's greatest contribution to the
Sci-Fi genre while many American
audiences still haven't given the film
its proper due critics and sci-fi Buffs
have rightly hailed it as a milestone
released in 1972 the film centers on
Chris Kelvin a psychologist who is sent
to a space station orbiting the planet
Solaris on a mission to assess the
mental condition of its crew following a
series of unexplainable emotional
breakdowns Chris soon begins to suffer
himself due to an unknown phenomenon
that has struck the station as he learns
more about the aliens and Solaris itself
Klein's experience also helps him deal
with the trauma that has haunted him for
years a spellbinding psychological drama
Solaris has always been highly acclaimed
but long underrated and underseen by
wider audiences that perhaps helps
explain why director Stephen Soderberg
and star George Clooney remade the film
in 2002 in an effort to shine a light on
an underappreciated classic you've taken
your first step into a larger word
George Lucas's sci-fi phenomenon Star
Wars was enough of a cultural Touchstone
that it deserved to be counted among the
best sci-fi films of the decade for its
Legacy alone Star Wars debuted to
massive crowds and lines that wrapped
around city blocks while children
skipped school and adults took off work
to go see it boasting groundbreaking
special effects the movie is a modern
day fairy tale about a young group of
Heroes Who band together to defeat an
evil Galactic Empire with its
unprecedented ticket sales and
mountainous merchandising Blitz Star
Wars changed the landscape of movies
forever every Studio wanted a piece of
the pie and while sequels were nothing
new in Tinseltown the era of Blockbuster
franchises and toy tie-ins truly began
in 1977 and it wasn't just the special
effects the lunch boxes and the box
office bucks either Star Wars was also a
well-crafted story with a heartfelt
emotional core despite being a
kid-friendly pulp comic book Space story
Allah Gordon critics were bowled over
showering the film with gushing praise
noted critic Roger Ebert who wasn't
typically impressed by flimsy
Blockbuster Fair happily awarded it four
stars and remarked on its awe-inspiring
nature no matter how you look at it when
it comes to Great 70 these sci-fi
Adventures Star Wars is unquestionably
King the 1970s were filled with great
science fiction movies that ran the
gamut from cerebral thought-provoking
message films to Breezy Space Adventures
but in 1979 an iconic film from
sophomore director Ridley Scott did
something truly staggering a grounded
realistic outer space Chiller that was
unlike anything audiences had
experienced before alien delivered a
story that expertly Blended horror and
science fiction screenwriter Dan
O'Bannon created a world that mixed the
lived-in grittiness of Star Wars with a
cast of ordinary men and women rather
than Larger than Life Heroes and
colorful creatures
these were not Intrepid space
adventurers but blue collar workers
long-haul space truckers dealing with an
extraordinary problem a deadly alien
stowaway that threatens to kill every
last one of them the terrifying creature
later known as a xenomorph would
instantly become one of Hollywood's
all-time greatest movie Monsters
Sigourney Weaver led the film as Ellen
Ripley an unlikely woman protagonist in
an era when dashing male Heroes
dominated the screen her impressive
performance inspired a generation as her
indomitable presence made Ripley a force
to be reckoned with issuing fast-paced
space action for slowly building tension
dripping with atmosphere the film's
stylish Direction gripping suspense and
sheer Terror elevates alien to the
greatest sci-fi movie of the 1970s
foreign
[Music]